what a year you've had you turned 18 and
you're about to go on the era store with
Taylor Swift how does that all work do
you get a personal phone call from
Taylor saying come on tour with me uh
actually I feel like obviously I've
known about Taylor for forever like my
whole entire life I can't remember a
time where I didn't know Taylor Swift
and being an up-and-coming songwriter in
Nashville specifically even like a pop
Rider in Nashville
um I accident I actually got nominated
for this award
um 10 songs that I wish I wrote and I
was one of the 10 songs and so my best
friend and I went to the awards show and
then Taylor Swift happened to be there
and I did a performance and some very
cool things happened after that you did
get a phone call
um it was not a phone call it was it was
it was in person where I got to meet her
and um it was it was incredible she went
up to you at the award show and said I'd
really love for you to go on tour with
me I mean it wasn't like it wasn't like
that she was just like you did a great
performance I'm gonna call you and
I can't believe it I feel like I'm lying
I feel like this is a dream I don't know
where I am I don't know what I'm doing
you deserve all the success have you
started thinking about your set list
will there be any Taylor covers I'm not
gonna do a Taylor Swift cover I feel
like for obvious reasons she's she does
it she does she does it all great I
don't need it I can't do it any better
uh there's a few covers I was thinking
of I was thinking of doing Tongue Tied
by Grouplove possibly Becky by Fletcher
so many things so many things Grammy
nominations are next week a lot of
people think your name is gonna be
called what would that mean to you
it means so much that if I talk about it
too much I will start crying I've been
doing music since I was seven I started
going to National 10. I moved there when
I was 12. it's everything I've wanted my
whole entire life and that
with all of the work and everything and
I feel I feel like there's a lot of
accomplishments that I've had this year
that feels like okay I put in work and
something's happening but that would be
everything it would just it would just
me it would mean so much even being here
it's just such an honor like everything
just feels like icing on the cake and a
cherry on top so if it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen I don't think it's gonna
happen but if it does
I would die I would die I would die
[Music]